we'll go to the next next story for
today insideclimate news winner of the
Pulitzer Prize / national reporting
doesn't even have an office it's a lean
operation today they have a staff of
seven but in the beginning there were
just two there's is a david-and-goliath
story three reporters working for a
five-year-old nonprofit with then just
four people took on the powerful oil
industry and told the world about the
biggest oil field they had never heard
of in the fall of 2011 is the national
debate on the Keystone XL pipeline was
ramping up Lisa Elizabeth and their
colleague david has Amir began reporting
on pipeline safety what would happen
they wanted to know if all pipelines
ruptured and spilled crude into the
rivers and the aquifers the primary
sources of water for drinking and
irrigation for the next 15 months they
traveled around the country to find
answers to that question they're
reporting took them to towns along the
Kalamazoo River in southwestern Michigan
in July 2010 a pipeline owned by the
canadian company Enbridge Inc was
ruptured dumping over a million gallons
of crude oil into the river the story
had been largely ignored by the media
when insideclimate news dug into it they
found many reasons why you and I should
be worried about pipeline safety one the
Enbridge pipeline had an extensive and
documented history of corrosion problems
yet regulators didn't press them to make
repairs to and which wasn't even
required by law to tell first responders
what the pipeline was carrying when it
ruptured 3 what the pipeline was
carrying was diluted bitumen or dilbit
the dirtiest stickiest oil on the market
bitumen is as thick as peanut butter so
it doesn't flow like most crude oil it
also has to be pinned with large amounts
of chemicals including the carcinogenic
benzene the team's findings go beyond
the Michigan
bill they're reporting revealed one the
technology used and most of the nation's
oil pipelines cannot detect spills and
two more effective technology is
available but federal regulators don't
require pipeline operators to use it not
for the plant Keystone pipeline or for
thousands of miles of other new and
repurpose pipelines that are being
planned since 2010 over a million
gallons of diluted bitumen has been
recovered from the site of the spill in
Michigan and bridge has spent close to
eight hundred million dollars for the
cleanup it's the most expensive oil
pipeline spill in US history and we
wouldn't have known much about it were
it not for insideclimate news Elizabeth
this is a classic you know waiting to be
told story in the beginning you weren't
even looking at the Michigan Lil Bit
disaster you were doing research and the
Keystone pipeline can you tell us how it
was you ended up reporting largely in
Michigan well yes I can excuse me I had
been hired in 2010 I was told to cover
the elections the federal elections from
an energy environment standpoint so I
parachuted into places ended up in
Nebraska because i thought the keystone
would be an issue it turns out the
people were very interested in the issue
the politicians were sort of giving it
the classic Heisman and not interested
in it so we were as I delved into this
we started to write more and more about
Keystone Lisa came on board she started
to investigate and we thought some we
need to tell a tale but we were not in
Michigan in 2010 when this spill
happened so the first we an editor we
had some conference calls about should
we go look at this so I did some
research went out to Kalamazoo and I
didn't get there until the fall of two
thousand eleven and I had done enough
leg work so I was able to see there's a
story here there are their health issues
there is there's the whole angle of this
diluted by
it's there are multiple angles but once
I found John LaForge who is the lead in
the story whose trail we follow
throughout the whole thing I thought we
have a story I mean this guy honestly I
talked to him more than my spouse I
think seven or eight months so we it
just had all the elements plus the
cleanup was still going on okay I I
think we have to introduce John deforge
do it I don't think everyone here read
the story right I mean own up everybody
how many here so tell us why John to
fortune why was that the key to your
story well he was a man who I called him
from my live in I live in Washington DC
remember we live all in different places
and are working out of our home or not
you know in one newsroom so every time
we want to communicate we're texting
emailing calling whatever so I had found
John the Forge and the first time I
called him he he said well he said I'd
like you to come out i'd be interested
in talking to you have to hold the phone
out here because this guy who's this
Forge voice and he he's a resident as a
resident comma 0 he lives in marshall
michigan which was ground zero for that
spill he had this peanut butter like
black goo wafting through his property
he had to be evacuated from his home his
whole family had to move to a hotel he
has never moved back to his home he he
built he did get a settlement from ember
and she built a new home so he became my
story and when I met him it was even
better i mean i thought this guy is out
of central casting I mean he's what
reporters look for so when I got out
there and had kind of he guided me
around and you know that's the magic of
reporting you have to do the legwork but
you have to be open-minded enough to
listen so that you don't get tunnel
vision and think this is my story and
i'm going to tell it this way so every
time he mentioned somebody I was going I
would you know one thing led to another
was this thing where you get one source
because I was putting together a
narrative but I
there when the narrative was halfway
through so I had to go back and try to
put the reader in the place what
happened to John LaForge the day that
that pipe started spewing oil into that
wet land where his and his house was
right near the creek and it just coded
his entire yard so strong character
riveting story that's one thing that
makes this series really great but the
other part of it is the science part
Lisa you have a science degree from MIT
so how did you begin even looking at the
scientific literature how did you even
figure out what you were looking for
well I I tried at first I I guess I got
pulled into this story about halfway
through Susan our editor said Lisa you
should help with the science and I
thought okay I'll just look up something
on google scholar but it didn't exist
there wasn't there were no peer-reviewed
journal articles about how dilbit
behaves when it spills into water so
then my plan B was to call up experts in
Canada they were University researchers
or industry scientists who work with
dilbit and none of them would return my
phone calls so that didn't work either
so I ended up going through as many
public documents as I could find there
were a couple of reports from the EPA
and there were some petroleum
engineering textbook someone found for
me and just really taking any tiny bit
of information I could find on the
chemistry of dilbit and then i would put
together these notes and give them to
oil spill experts in the US and these
were people who had never worked with
dilbit but they had worked on the BP oil
spill or you know they had worked in
other they had worked with noah and the
US Fish and Wildlife Service and they
knew enough chemistry that I would give
them little bits and pieces and they
could put together the story for me so
they were able to tell me that yes you
know given the little bit of information
you've given me this is how the oil
would react this is it makes sense that
you know after a few days most of the
light chemicals would evaporate which is
when the heavy oil sinks and that's why
you have a problem
so that's how I approach the science and
then the other thing that really helped
was inside climate sent me to an I re
boot camp for journalists on Excel and
access and having that skill set was was
really helpful we were able to
fact-check and pull out interesting
tidbits from the air monitoring that EPA
had done after the spill because they
were trying to figure out how much
benzene was in the air and was it safe
for people to breathe so that helped
there and also using one of the federal
databases on pipeline safety I was able
to figure out for follow-up story that
most of during most of the oil pipeline
spills in the country the software that
they have for detecting spills is pretty
much useless so only five percent of
those spills were detected by the
company's technology and that was again
really helpful the interesting finding
in this series was that the federal
regulators didn't even know it was going
on at the time it was right the way the
regulations are set up the regulator's
know if a pipeline contains crude oil or
a natural gas or you know compressed co2
or something like that but they don't
know what type of crude oil is in the
pipeline and the company didn't tell the
EPA or anyone exactly what type of oil
was in the line and people found out
because I think it was a week after the
spill some scientist walked into the
river and all this oil started bubbling
up from the bottom of the river and
that's when they realized they had a
problem and also there were some local
reporters at the time it was a mishit
Michigan messenger they questioned the
CEO of the company a lot and sort of got
him to admit it was still bit this this
is essentially a narrative of an oil
spill and there are so many moving parts
to it I mean how did you put that
chronology together I mean what what
were your main sources of information
for example how did you find out
regularly
no hard to find out what the what the
company told the regulators of that
right well we were we were gathering
from every that's why we had to bring in
Lisa because it was just getting too
huge we had all this science and when
you're trying to advance a story you can
tell a great story but we wanted to back
it up with the science even if it was
just a parenthetical phrase or maybe a
paragraph so all of that research we
were doing and and I think that we were
sort of learning what like with the EPA
that the fact that they were talking to
me the federal government isn't exactly
cooperative on many levels you will find
out but I think they were hoping that we
would get some answers that maybe they
weren't getting so they were sharing
information which which was very helpful
so it was a matter of i mean i threw out
a rough draft so that we could see all
our holes but we knew we needed to chat
and we had to do our due diligence I
mean we've had to be accurate so this
was going over and over and over things
calling you know people in Washington
checking with the people in Michigan I
mean it is a constant back and forth
you're an online-only news organization
to the smallest staff in a small budget
and you're taking on the oil industry
that's that's not easy right no that's
why you use a tape recorder when you're
in the room with Enbridge and therefore
of them and one of you what obstacles
did you face I mean where did you feel a
lawsuit for example what did you have
enough resources to continue the
reporting did you have enough editorial
support yeah I mean when we started this
I didn't know what it was going to turn
into I felt like I was building a
geometric shape that maybe hadn't been
invented yet and so yes the fear I mean
fear drives you because you can't afford
to make a mistake so we I mean I would
send paragraphs to end bridge and say
this is what we're writing can you
please and I mean they were so tired of
me but I my phrase was look it
have to be accurate and and this is this
is my name this is all I have is a
journalist we cannot afford to make a
mistake so you have to work with me we
did that with everybody going over and
over I mean hundreds of phone calls and
reviewing of databases so it's yeah it
is a little scary especially when the
day before you're going to publish in
burge says to you you know Elizabeth
that wasn't diluted by two men that
spilled that was just heavy crude oil
and you knew that it was diluted by two
men because we had but still your hearts
kind of popping out of your body at that
point so did you did you get legal it
was did you get legal advice with your
story reviewed by a lawyer were there
any fears of the legal consequences if
you went on through the stone yeah we
did we we had an attorney going over
everything because they're there were
those fears that we were in over our
heads or that we had said things but we
felt I mean we SAT and read this thing
to one another I mean you know I'm in
Washington leases in Boston our editors
in California we're reading and looking
for holes and then having other people
read it and looking for holes I mean we
had as many people as possible going
over this thing so what one question our
students always ask is when you get in
touch with a company with a bad guy in
your story at what point do you make
contact with your target with with
enrich yeah oh I mean right off the bat
I set up an interview before i even went
to michigan for the first time and they
sat down with me and they were very open
because i told them this is what we're
trying to do we're trying to put
together the chronology of the spill now
you know after that I mean I basically
spent seven months from the time I first
went to Michigan to the time we
published and you know by the fifth
month Jason the spokesperson from
Enbridge was really sick of me Elizabeth
when are you going to be done I said
we'll be done when we're finished with
this but I can't I don't know when
because we need to fill in all the way
did you get the same kind of openness
from the
from the federal regulators the EPA and
the EPA was was very open on this case
we I was we were very fortunate there
and I built good bonds with those people
the Department of Transportation see
it's it's a strange situation because
it's a it's a branch of the Department
of Transportation that does the
regulating they didn't really need to
tell us that they didn't know what they
were doing because they often had so
much trouble answering our questions I
felt like we should be working there and
they should be doing our job so that
just became abundantly clear but you
can't just say that because that's what
how you feel about something we had to
prove that which we were able to do with
congressional testimony and with other
you know pieces that we put together and
Lisa putting together those charged to
show you know the Fox is clearly
guarding the henhouse Lisa what were you
going to say so I had want the one
agency that was really knew what they
were doing was the National
Transportation Safety Board because they
launched an investigation as soon as the
spill happened and they put out their
final report about two weeks after we
had published this story but before they
put out the final report they released
10,000 pages of their raw notes and so
the inside climate News publisher and i
just spent weeks going over those notes
and using it to fact-check everything
we'd written and pulling out any
interesting little details we could like
from those notes and from their
timelines we discovered that a right
after the spill Enbridge called their PR
department before they told the federal
government so just little things like
that that were really helpful and made
sure that everything we'd written was
correct so what was the impact of this
story I mean it's easy to have impact
easier to have impact on speeding cops
harder I think to have an impact on
pipeline safety yeah I mean clearly that
the pipeline problem has not been been
solved and that's going to be a long
journey it seems as if we have the
public is becoming more
where that pipelines even exist I mean
it's sort of like the ocean you throw
things in it we don't see them most
pipelines are buried now I mean we have
become we kind of put dilbit into the
vocabulary for one thing people became
aware of it then with this whole
Keystone publicity I think it's meshed
where people say oh pipelines for some
reason I need to pay attention to that
so you know has Congress come out and
rewritten laws has the regulatory agency
under do t come out and written a whole
bunch of new regs and rules no they
haven't but it's on the radar screen and
the public is pushing for this
especially in places where pipelines
exist or our plans one of the things he
said that was that the people who live
near the Kalamazoo River didn't even
know there was a pipeline in their
community yeah your turn to ask
questions please come up and those of
you want to ask just line up near the
mics and there's another one over there
hi I'm Charlotte I was wondering why
your opinion on why you think this was
the biggest oils that would never heard
of until you guys came along was it just
a timing thing like that for the Gulf
oil spill we would have heard about it
or do you think there was sort of other
issues at play as to why it wasn't
reported earlier you know I think you're
right about the Gulf spill that had
happened just a few months previous and
everybody was still obsessed with
watching that camera and all that oil
pouring out of there and this oil
spilled in a wetland went into a creek
went into the Kalamazoo River they ended
up closing 38 to 40 miles of the river
it did not reach the Great Lakes but in
the first couple days the EPA was
absolutely panicked because if it
reached the Great Lakes where millions
of people get their drinking water then
you would have heard about it and we
wouldn't have had this story in the same
way but it was the Gulf spill was
huge plus it was kind of the Upper
Midwest and you know people look at that
as fly over territory for some reasons
so yes as newsrooms continue to shrink
you know more and more people are going
to be doing what you do which is you
know working from home or collaborating
remotely what would you say are the
advantages and disadvantages of doing
what you do would you prefer to have a
newsroom would you prefer to have a
physical newsroom i think is the
question it would be helpful to have a
physical newsroom but i mean i do enjoy
not having a commute and sometimes
working in my pajamas and stuff and can
be very comfortable working from home
but there were definitely moments
throughout this collaboration when I
thought it would be so much easier if we
were in the same room in the same time
zone you know we would do things like
send each other files may be the wrong
versions of a draft or something then
you can't call the other person because
they're out awake yet 6am they're just
crazy stuff like that and it's so much
easier to brainstorm and discuss ideas
when you can see each other's faces and
all we did was have disembodied voices
on the phone but you know our running
joke became because we were so obsessed
with this and it was we were devoting so
much of our staff and we had sort of
become we became a niche publication we
thought we should become inside pipeline
news because that's what we were doing
because when you take that many people
off of the daily stuff and you know with
the web you've got to feed the beast all
the time and we were having to find
other ways to do that so it was for the
grace of the rest of the staff that they
were willing to say this evidently is
important enough to us to continue with
this so it's it was an experiment kind
of a little bit of a seat-of-the-pants
experiment so so the gentleman over
there yes I mean y'all probably know now
probably about as much if not more about
the regulatory apparatus for these
things and any
one else in the country at this point
and my question is you know what what
were the big problems you discovered in
terms of what was wrong and what if
anything is sort of like the no-brainer
fixes that could prevent maybe xanthus
from happening well I can start I mean
what one thing that's wrong is that
people don't know what is flowing
through these pipelines the the location
of pipelines when you look at a map if
the agency is called finsih that the sub
agency under do t they don't want
terrorists to know exactly where those
lines are so they will be sort of where
they are they'll be in Michigan but not
necessarily near the kalamazoo river so
that part you know the end that the
safety measures I mean you for instance
we did a story where where they talked
about the Keystone XL taking having 57
new safety measures and we dug into all
of them 12 of them actually would
improve safety the rest of them were
just a bunch of blather so I don't I I
think those are the big problems that
you were finding out pipelines were made
of subpar materials and that they aren't
maintained and that really fem so relies
on the actual companies to report
problems plus they're allowed to be
fined and not have to fix problems i
mean the breaches along Enbridge the 6b
pipeline were clear and they weren't
forced to to repair any of them they
would be able to get delays I think when
it comes to dilbit dilbit as a product
we've only been transporting and
pipelines in large quantities since 1999
so it's not regulated any differently
from regular crude oil but it behaves
differently when it spills so that's
obviously a gap in the regulations and n
like Elizabeth said if you don't know
what's in the pipeline when it spills
you don't know how you're supposed to
manage the cleanup you know and it can
be very crucial in those first few hours
to know what's the best way to clean it
up quickly and whether or not people
need to be evacuated the health issue is
huge with this because of the benzene so
you know the the
the head of femme so says pipelines and
people shouldn't mix but they clearly
are mixing because people are building
subdivisions on pipelines as we speak
and nobody knows they're there and just
to clarify one point so the agency is
the power to fine but not to require
fixes or something into that nature they
can do both but they seem to be they be
they are able to get they don't have
companies meeting deadlines there are
constant extensions and it's it's this
weird grey area thank you hi do you
think that being a smaller more niche
organization helped you get get a higher
level of access especially to the big
corporations like for instance do you
think a New York Times or Washington
Post pursuing the same story would have
faced certain obstacles that that you
didn't know I just think it was I think
that maybe it was because they were like
well we don't know who you are I guess
we'll talk to you I mean with its so
it's uh but no I think that we I think
anybody could have pursued this story we
just did it because we saw it as a place
that was under covered and thought wow
we could maybe make something out of
this yeah I last question hi you
mentioned that you were kind of told by
the execs that if you keep writing about
this they would be speaking to their
friends in Bloomberg so I was wondering
can you give us a bit more context and
how did you deal with that did you just
like ignore that oh that was I think
that that was after it was after you
left yeah oh so this was once david has
Meyer joined us and started writing
about landowners where land owners were
complaining about em bridge because
Enbridge was building a brand new larger
pipe line parallel to the existing one
and they were
donors with conflicts they said they
were being bullied by the company stuff
like that and at one point Enbridge
called our editor Susan white and said
you know we think you've written enough
stories now about this new pipeline you
should stop you've already written two
or three that that's all you have to do
and obviously we didn't stop and then
they said if you keep writing will call
our friends at bloomberg news and and
Bloomberg syndicate's some of our
stories and that's a big deal because
they have a lot of their readers are a
different audience than the people who
read our website but I guess our editor
and publisher decided you know if that
happened then it was going to happen
that we weren't going to stop reporting
so so thank you